from property brother to proper dancer
drew Scott has come a long way from his
Dancing with the Stars debut and we were
with him every step of the way I'm gonna
rally all of the country to come support
because I have the most amazing coach
and we're gonna get you a second mirror
ball
[Music]
I'm trying to squeeze in dancing
anywhere I can legit I just came from
two hours of dancing and then right
after this book signing we got on a
plane we fly to Cincinnati and I do
another four hours so I'm trying to
squeeze in that's why I've been getting
like four hours of sleep at night that
man just snapped you know em and I were
going through our rehearsal and felt
like I got a massive kick to the back of
the hamstring and I could even walk on
it right now I can't bend my leg and put
weight on it so I don't know what we're
gonna do for tomorrow I was trying to
improve upon the things that Len gave me
feedback on I can't actually perform
that way because of this that's gonna
tick me off
[Applause]
it just got a bit sort of loose in the
actual dance going there but you know
keep it up keep working along and we'll
see what happens I love all the
criticism and in the positive I love
everything I take it all this feedback
that's gonna help us get stronger so
we're gonna work on everything the
judges said
dancing gonna have a busted ankle I have
pulled hamstrings I have bruises
everywhere but I'm loving it
also dancing in the finals are
drew and Emma
[Applause]
I hope all of Canada is behind me voting
go to team hot property calm because
this is your gonna make the difference